quando passa esse voo da cadeira mexe
sozinha câmera da casa antiga criança
falando com amiga invisível cadeira se
mexe sozinha macho vai embora dessa casa
por favor aí o cara vai perguntar pra
filha com quem que ela tá conversando e
as meninas não quer dizer não me conta
filha com quem você estava conversando
você tem um amigo invisível a menininha
responde só assim eu não quero falar
sobre ele Isso aí é filme Se fosse lá em
casa era assim quem é esse amiguinho teu
hein Ah quer dizer que agora tem
amiguinho do satanás tu vai aprender a
ter amigo de verdade ó hum e eu quero
milho saber que tu tá andando com esse
tal de satanás aí viu eu tenho para mim
que esse Satanás tem um amigo e usa
droga Aí o cara de noite é esse para
beber leite para beber leite a casa tá
assombrada a menina conversa com o cão
Cara filmou o cão ele desce para beber
leite e deixa a luz apagada esse povo de
filme é burro os cara não acende a luz
da casa liga a luz meu amigo e para de
beber leite beber água